[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de plus en plus les shadoks était pris
au cerveau des rats ces deux génies tu
cérébrale les plus touchés dont on n'est
même plus leur langue maternelle des
pauvres malheureux se mettait à parler
des idiomes et patois parfaitement tasse
à battre le vocabulaire shadoks normal
c'est bien connu avait quatre mots vous
disiez hammouche haddock quelconque moi
ça faisait venir en même temps troyes
demi-douzaine de machin du poignet
s'appeler comme ça de passoire toi le
promu la caf est plus ou moins germain
la tour eiffel des qualités la liberté
n'a pas qualité plus toute une famille
d'entonnoir arch
comme tous les maux shadow que voulait
dire approximativement la même chose
c'était très facile de soutenir une
conversation mais les shadoks prix du
cerveau si on les laissait se dire des
mots qui voulait dire précisément des
choses c'était là pour google il ya les
petits copeaux la longue verbal tous
deux ont discuté
rustique les plus vendus et alors là ça
serait la fin de la belle civilisation
shadoks et celle de l'émission par la
même occasion les shadoks malades
étaient recyclés dare-dare par
ordinateur pour ce faire réinjecter les
bonnes manières de la grammaire
premièrement et primo que mon chat d'oc
qui ne veut rien dire ne peut pas dire
deux fois de suite la même chose seconde
nous et en plus il est interdit d'y
déposer dépôt d'interrogation
d'infirmation d'appréciation d'exécution
ou de n'importe quoi donnons toute
proposition constipé par une passoire
après 10 heures du mat tout génitif
qualificatif cumulatif ou des ponots
ayant eu des rapports avec son
complément pantin point virgule au
pluriel sauf si c'est un hibou un genou
à je joue un peu on a récupéré pas mal
grammaticalement mais il n'y en avait
encore des malheureux qui se démoraliser
et ne croyaient plus principe moral
shadoks de base qui disait pour qu'il y
ait le mois de mai comptant possible il
faut toujours taper sur les nerfs
cela les shadows qu'on s'en occuper tout
spécial
[Musique]